hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the semi-finals of the ftx
uh uh crypto cup knockouts it's tamura
java vs magnus carlsen and you guys
started suggesting this one as soon as
it finished as if i
wasn't going to cover it of course i am
and it's uh well
rajabov is in a really tight spot he
needs a win to bounce back into the
match because after the two draws magnus
won the third game
and now rajabov needs a win to bounce
back and go uh well
uh with leveled chances for the second
match tomorrow
so now he has the white pieces and let's
see what he decides
to do for this one and yes uh this one
is another saga of the light square
bishop so let's see uh how it goes we
have d4 by rajabo
uh knight to f6 we have c4 e6 knights to
f3
uh and d5 now we have knight to c3
yeah so just a nice queen's gambit to
decline this on the board and bishop to
b4 going for the eregos in defense
uh we have bishop to g5 by uh job of end
now
h6 challenging this bishop asking do you
want to go back do you want to throw in
queen to a for check there are a lot of
very interesting ideas
or do you just want to capture on f6 so
here at a job of captures we have queen
captures
and only now queen to a for check you
have to block this with the knight
otherwise you're going to lose the
bishop so knight to c6
and now e3 so this is nothing new this
has all been played before many times
we have castle by castles by magnus and
rook to c1 now
we have queen the g6 now hindering the
development of the light square bishop
as the g2 pawn will be under attack
and uh rajab of plays h4 so going very
aggressive
aggressive he needs a win here so
there's really no time to
play pass if he wants to bring the rook
into the game then maybe start attacking
the queen
and already have a rook ready for the
attack on the black king and here
there are a couple of moves that are
known here like bishop to d7 d
captures on c4 is known but the move
magnus place is a new one
so already as of move uh 10 we have a
completely new game and that is a rook
to d8
so let's see how rajab deals with this
he continues uh with his
uh pawn pushing on the king side with h5
queen to f6 and now rook to h4 now
he can play rook to f4 and further
harass the black queen
uh and the magnus now uh uh you
you we need to keep in mind that magnus
is now leading the match so magnus only
needs a draw here and he would very much
enjoy a compositional game where he can
just maneuver his uh
knights maybe push a pawn here and there
and claim a draw but magnus never plays
like this
most of the times and uh he he could
simply just for example characters
captures continued development
now black white queen probably needs to
go back uh and then he's gonna further
develop however
uh here he says uh nope rajabov's king
is still in the center of the board it's
time to open up the center and
this is uh in general a very principled
idea
so here we have c copper on d5 we have
rook captures on d5 as the knight cannot
capture the knight is pinned
and now d captures an e5 with an attack
on the black queen
and now you can't really play knight
captures on e5 because then
uh well the bishop is no longer defended
and after we capture it the queen also
defends the rook so it's not a problem
even if you eliminate one defender
the queen still guards the rook so here
black is just down material and of
course
black can resign here so instead magnus
first eliminates the knight with
check we have rook captures on c3 and
now
knight captures an e5 but now he allows
timur to go for queen to e8 to check and
this is not very pleasant so queen to e8
check king to h7 and now rook to f4
attacking the carlton's queen and now
magnus brings it to d6 and this is the
uh well start of a very very difficult
game for magnus uh here he had a chance
to maybe play queen to b6 as uh
you have to move the queen so why not
move the queen with tempo you get
an attack on the b2 pawn but he decided
to play queen to d6 instead
and now it's uh well it's a problem
because white can play many things but
white can also just play bishop to e2
just continue development as uh well you
don't want to play something weird and
then suffer with something like rook to
d1
check so bishop to e2 is a must guarding
that d1 square and now magnus plays f5
and it's a pretty crazy position
uh like i said not something you want to
have in in a game where a draw is enough
to win the match but it is exactly what
rajab
wants for his last game where he has the
white pieces and here that tamer plays
knight to d4 just for the fun of it
because i know how much you guys enjoy
it
i will show a line that's uh that's
pretty much an instant win but it's a
very unnatural to play such a move uh
rook to d4 uh knight to d4 is a
a lot more natural because you you kind
of don't want to allow this trade and
you want to get your
sort you want to get your knight here to
attack the f51 but rook to d4 is
extremely powerful
to give you an example let's say black
trades here for example captures
captures and now further
trace captures captures uh there is
really no good move here for black the
bishop can't go anywhere
as the rook would fall the queen doesn't
really have any good squares because the
c7 pawn falls
so you can't really capture on d4 or
anything and other than that you really
don't have any any good moves so here
this is just
lost for black and and if you try to go
for this and allow it
then i mean there there's no playing
this for example queen captures bishop
d5 that's it there's no defending
against checkmate
a few checks here and there you're going
to avoid them very easily
you're going to come to f3 for example
queen a3 let's say we block with the
bishop
and now there is no defending checkmate
you have to move the bishop a lot queen
captures an a8 and so on
so although this is a very very strong
it's a rapid game of course you don't
want to allow this and knight to d4 much
more natural so this is what temu goes
for
and now the f5 phone cannot be defended
so what can magnus do here
not much whatever you do you can't
really move the queen away from the
defense of the c7 pawn rook captures on
the c7
it's just devastating so here magnus
tries a different
idea he plays c6 now the situation on
the queen side is
well under control uh we could say uh
but now the f5 pawn falls so knight
captures on f5
and you cannot even trade here because
the rook would still hang
so here we have queen to d8 now magnus
offers a queen trade
he says all right uh let's go into the
end game i'm a pretty good end game
player
doesn't matter that i'm down upon uh
rajabov happily accepts this we have
captures captures
and now the knight goes back uh knight
to d4
now you could also consider maybe knight
to h4 with the idea of shifting the
knight over to g6 at some point
but like it's a rapid game you you don't
really have all the time
uh in the world to you know think about
all the quant consequences
so knight back to d4 and now uh magnus
starts bringing his pieces into the game
and like uh rajabo in the previous game
carlson's bishop here the light squad
bishop really doesn't have any good
squares all of this is taken so you have
to be
you have to play something because this
rook if it remains there then you can
simply resign so here
uh bishop the d4 bishop to d7 was played
and now comes rook to e4 magnus
doesn't allow magnus to develop he
attacks the knight rook to e8 defending
hoping to bring the other rook into the
game but now
rook to c5 with a double attack on the
knight
knight to f7 now he offers a trade but
now bishop to d3 of
uh threatening a lot of very nasty
discoveries so here
king the h8 by magnus and then now comes
rook
captain sorry trades off a pair of rooks
uh we have
b for now preparing to further expand on
the queen side
and knight the d6 by magnus so maybe he
can still hold this he's only down one
pawn
uh but his king is very uh well
uh not all that active he's all the way
on h8 and
you know even if we trade everything
down the white king will have a much
easier task of of joining the game than
the black king
so here uh we have uh bishop to g6 now
attacking this rook also placing this
bishop to a very nice square
rook to e7 and now comes a4 so just
continuing with his plan
we have king to g8 the king is in a
really bad position here
uh if this rook ever for example reaches
if the king remains there and this rook
for example reaches
the back rank somehow that's it there's
no defending uh checkmate
so king to g8 you have to start bringing
your king into the game
and arajabov does the same king e2 and
also he might have some f3e4 ideas in
the future so here
knight the e4 by magnus uh and here
although you could capture this for
example captures captures and then we
continue with f3 e4 and so on
uh he decides to keep uh the tension on
the board so here he just goes back the
rook is under attack
rook to c2 and now knight to f6
we have b5 he continues attacking on the
queen side
uh and now you have to capture because
there is a triple attack now on the c6
square
so captures on b5 captures and now a6
now with the spawn push magnus creates a
pawn on the queen side so now he's the
one that's gonna start pushing
uh we have b captures b captures and now
rook to b2 now preparing to shift to the
rook all the way to the back ring
and as you can see this is a lot of a
lot of problem
uh for for the black king so here
bishop e8 hoping to get this trade in
but
uh of course uh javo just pins the
bishop uh we have king to f8 now
defending it
uh three times so now maybe the rook can
move uh and now
knight to f5 preparing to bring yet
another attacker to the bishop so of
course magnus
has to stop this he plays rook e6 but
now rook the a8 and here
uh it's very very hard to even find the
move for magnus magnus now can activate
one of the pieces
he tries knight to d5 uh hoping to get
some
knight to f4 check action maybe so uh
you can maybe pick up the bishop here on
g6
but now rajab spots this and he just
trades captures
uh we have rook captures uh sorry rook
captures
uh in the now uh well you could play
something like rook captures king
captures and eliminated this pawn with
check it's kind of more human to
eliminate the a6 pawn because
why leave uh the opponent with an
outside pass pawn so here
uh the job of just uh picks up this pawn
but now he has to give up this pawn so
knight f4
check the the e pawn is pinned uh we
have king of three
knight captures on h5 and now it's a a
little bit
uh more bearable for magnus because the
pawns are now
all the pawns are now on the kings side
and he's only down one pawn but
the the problem is there's a move that
uh wins the game on the spot basically
for for a job of so feel free to pause
the
video here and try to find this move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
being a true master of the end game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course
g4 and now you can see that this knight
really has no squares he does have the
f6 square but as you'll see
that's simply not enough knight to f6
was played that's the only available
square to the knight but now of course
comes
knight captures on h6 this was rajabov's
idea
and now if the knight is captured we
eliminate this guy with
check and now after the king moves it's
just three pawns against one
uh two of those pawns are past pawns so
it's completely winning for
uh for taymor here so after knight
captures on h6 magnus has to
rely on some tricks to maybe save the
game he goes knight to e4
and now just knight back to f5 so now
rajabov is up two pawns and this is now
completely winning
uh but uh i mean there are still uh
there's still a rook and the knight in
the game magnus will of course
do his best to pose as many problems for
a job
as possible knight to g5 check king g2
and not rook to b8 maybe trying if those
pawns are
start marching forward maybe you can
start harassing the the white king with
the knight and the rook because
uh there is no greater team in chess
than a rook and the knight okay maybe
the bishops pair but if it's a very nice
fully operational bishop fair
so here we have knight back to d4 and
now king to f7
magnus tries activating the king a
little bit we have rook to a5 now
attacking the knight
knights the e4 and now comes rook to e5
so the job of centralizes the rook
forces the knight to move
knight back to f6 and only now f3 so now
slowly
uh the king will find its way uh you
know
in black's half of the the position so
g6 by magnus is now king g3
we have rooked a b1 trying something but
now
rook to b5 here rajab offers uh a trade
of rooks of course uh
you shouldn't agree to this but then
again there's really not all that much
you can play
if you deliver a check king f4 and now
you know pawns are just marching forward
the rook can push the king further back
you can even start bringing the king
deeper into the position
so instead after rook to b5 magnus
actually traded rooks here we have
captures captures
and now g5 so maybe you can still hold
this but it's a very very unlikely
knight the c3 was played
we have king to g6 and here uh rajabo
just played f4
and it was in this position on 54 that
magnus carlsen resigned to the game
and by doing so our job of now equalize
the match and tomorrow we're going to
have
a very very exciting matchup as who wins
tomorrow wins the
the semifinals and is going into the
finals so that's it for this match we're
going to check out
the other match as well as that's also
some really really incredible chess
being played here by annie pondich and
wesley so
stay tuned for that as well and here you
resign as
i mean it's three pawns against one but
for those of you who are maybe new to
chess
to show you how hopeless the position is
it doesn't matter
you never gain anything by capturing
here you just
make a white's life easier and if you
try to do
anything waste moves we can just uh you
know do anything let's say knights to e4
now we offer a trade if the knight
doesn't trade then we pick up we pick up
this pawn
if we trade then we can just get the
king into the game let's say this is now
completely winning
and if you don't do this there's like
nothing you can do if you try knight to
h7 then this is just
silly we can even just play this knight
captures knight capped respawn captures
and now it's again it doesn't matter
that we've breaking our pawn structure
this is completely winning
so after f4 magnus resigns and for those
of you who guessed that correctly
congratulations again because uh this is
what magnus said in an interview after
the game i blundered and he played well
thank you and see you tomorrow and then
he shut down the
the the uh the the live stream as uh i
i imagine he wasn't very interested in
giving an interview after
a game like this uh but yeah i
congratulations to everyone who
solved the position and also who sold uh
the mystery behind who
who who said this uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it like i
said we are going to cover
uh the other match as well i would like
to thank lee roberts
daniel grabowski uh jesse brunson
christian manza
and david kimura for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day